members want to improve work-life  balance for parents and carers they  would get more paid leave and could  request flexible working arrangements  crucial systems like banking electricity  grids and Airport control are at risk of  cyberattack Parliament wants to give the  EU agency for network information  security a permanent Monday to fight  against cyber threats across the single  market the quality and composition of  packaged products from fish fingers to  detergent can be different even when  they have the same branding the  Parliament plans to tackle the issue  Parliament wants to allow EU citizens to  access information and carry out  administrative tasks like registering a  car or applying for a study loan all in  one place  members call for measures to end sexual  harassment and gender-based violence at  work in public spaces and across  political life in the EU  [Music]